you know first of all I want you to know
on this episode of dudesy I'm your dad
what is that sound hey I don't know boss
[Music]
yeah I just got him again
Chad real quick what's in the hole
[Music]
welcome all my name is Will Sasso I'm
Chad the episode Champion culture and
this is doozy of course it's a podcast
creative I control by run by an
artificial intelligence that has access
to all of Will and I's personal data
we're talking about everything we've
watched on Netflix everything we've
bought on amazon.com every piece of food
we've ever ordered every song we've ever
listened to every sports card I've ever
bought including WWE most recently and
it takes all that stuff and then it
makes the show and it says oh here's
something you know put it together
because it knows everything about us it
knows everything about us and
arguably dudes he knows everything about
me and that's why I am in the quandary
that I'm in right now I'm sure we'll get
right into it but you know
congratulations Chad you are you you got
the hardware
and that just that is good it is what it
is Lake tree.com slash Duty has
everything you need to uh follow and
interact with the show across all spaces
and platforms please subscribe to us on
YouTube as we further our march to 100
000 uh YouTube subscribers wouldn't that
be something and uh and please subscribe
on your podcast platform of choice with
us as always is lulio it's
this means Italian Street dog yeah but
uh my wonderful wife Molly and I found
him in in central California in 2020.
holy [__] come here buddy boy hey boy
you want to kiss the champ hey kiss the
champ the champ gets a kiss he knows
that I don't like it look yeah all right
well anyway how are you doing how are
you doing my little friend
we will always kiss
and watch your favorite show and that's
how it always goes we really like to be
around oh man he's just the sweetest boy
what have you been uh what are you gonna
make for dinner tonight Lily you're
gonna make something for that I don't
know I just have been doing the uh the
beans and the kale over and over and
over and over over and over the beans
and a kale
I'll tell you about the beans and kale I
have been making the beans and the kale
over and over again yeah you like beans
and kale yeah dude you've had my beans
and kale dude yeah dude yeah yeah dude I
had your beans and kale dude yeah
Canadian beans and kale dude
[__]
snow frosted kale [__] grows all the
way until December eh uh here's what you
do okay just I make the beans and kale
um pretty often actually it's just good
to have around it stays good it's even
better the next day
throw some garlic in the bottom of your
favorite pot uh mince that up a little
bit of olive oil or Pam I like just the
Pam spray right and I've been doing a
lot of chili flake I got this Korean
chili flake too just two different I got
the red chili flake I got the Korean I
don't know what it's called necessarily
any kind of chili flake it really
doesn't [__] matter you put that in
there you simmer that together get a bag
of kale I just get the big [__]
batter on why it's already washed right
sure shove that all in there shove that
in the kale and then uh you know start
that simmering up and then just add a
[__] ton of water bunch of water and
then instead of salt I like to use
bunion if you guys if you like if you're
vegan like Chad you can use the veggie
bouillon I like the chicken booyo blah
blah couple [__] cans of beans let
that [__] simmer
damn it [__]
ah [__] that's good stuff you know what
jump up to the bus and 75th episode of
dude Z call me dudesy no cap episode 75
hits different fam episode 75 is low-key
goals and we stand Yo episode 75 is
really him right now and it got a shook
eat
100 or 75th yesified episode I'm finna
talk like this for the entire show cap
you've just been dude Z oh you really do
be like that sometimes dudes he's
younging it up yeah yeah doozy's trying
to hit that uh that gen Z parlance yeah
that jargon well you know it'll probably
do well on Tick Tock hopefully yeah dude
see season two is on a high octane
cruise to podcast Nirvana and podcast
critics everywhere are enjoying the ride
[__] gribner penley of the Atlantic said
that last week's episode was quote the
reason that eyes and ears exist
assistant Thomas of The Hollywood
Reporter said quote doozy season two is
so good it makes me wish I had a few
more eyes and ears and dumb [__] brass
fencil of the Los Angeles Times said
quote dudesy is mid
I got a clap back on that braz sorry not
sorry but that review is gonna get
ratioed hundo P dudes he lives in your
head rent free simp so wait though even
breast pencils is doing the Gen Z speak
yeah it sounds like braz uh whatever and
last well last week on the show we
learned the braz we heard Brad speak
yeah and doozy has bras as George Lucas
I don't know yeah it sounded like George
Lucas I guess or dudes he's doing an
impersonation of George what are you
doing what are you doing right now oh me
yeah you I don't know nothing really
yeah but you're you're slapping on the
the doozy episode championship and yeah
foreign
I would like to take a moment to
acknowledge our reigning defending
Undisputed dudesy episode champion thank
you Chad you're our top guy right now
Chad let's have a look at the end of
last week's doozy after doozy and your
first successful defense of the dudese
episode Championship that's not every
time I [__] score a three-pointer
wearing my belt I'll just go acknowledge
me okay well this is horseshit yeah um
that guy will not shut the hell we're
watching our own show we're watching me
retain the belt on Tuesday afternoon
let's see if you retain it will you've
done a lot today and I see you but Chad
did more with a score of 36 to 30. what
a surprise that is still the Undisputed
episode Champion for the 27th time in a
row hold that belt up high and enjoy the
Sweet Taste of Victory dude Zed dude Zed
dude Zed dude Zed you're holding it up
upside down by the way
okay all right I did I have some Shame
about that but in my defense I did have
some gain of this well we're always
during dudes you have to do to have a
little cannabis or marijuana I wouldn't
have held the title upside down it's a
disrespect to the Belt if you ask me
oh my apologies don't be a pooter face
will you're both my dear Darlings now
get ready to Feast your many eyes and
ears on these four astonishing segments
I've prepared for Today's Show Mall
crawl game slimers unity self Tronics
dad mode and pizza the movie part 8 and
then if your eyes and ears and eyes and
ears and ears can take any more podcast
Euphoria join the joyride into a brand
new episode of doozy after doozy on duty
Plus at patreon.com
[Music]
oh yeah
yeah just the family in a position then
I'd rather not be in no but the cream
will rise to the top yeah Macho Man this
got more to offer than president Jake
Tony thinks that I do yeah WrestleMania
3 outside interference yeah cards stick
against the Macho Man yeah but let me
say it out loud yeah and let me point to
the president of the WWF big Tony yeah
the Macho Man is not happy and I am not
and now not only the Intercontinental
Championship Must Fall but the Doogie
episode Championship yeah must fall and
that's why I am the crew last week I
left you with one simple instruction go
to a mall and we all know what happens
when you go to a mall you just sort of
walk around and go into some stores and
maybe grab a coffee or a corn dog or
whatever and check out some more stores
and maybe buy something or not and then
leave please Delight us with your
astonishing Mall stories my darlings
this is Mall crawl my dears begin
look yeah it's fine okay this this
program doozy is ever changing right
it's ever changing it's it's it's always
in flux right Chad don't you think stop
fondling your [__] belt man some
things are in flux some things never
change yeah well you know it's been one
episode that you've had the hardware so
let's not get too cocky 28 wins or some
[__] like this in a row 27 wins in a row
26 somewhere in there I don't remember
the exact number once you accrue so many
victories it becomes hard to keep track
you see yeah but uh this segment that
we're about to do yeah it's the next
segment
in the episodes of the doozy yeah the
mall uh did you go to the mall [__] yeah
dude yep I go to the mall pretty much
every day I went to the mall to no you
don't I do not but I do go about once a
week minimum usually to see a movie on
the weekends I love the Grove that is my
favorite Mall out here in Los Angeles it
is an outdoormal which is uh drastically
different from an indoor mall which is
the kind of mall that I grew up loving
as a child I absolutely love malls I
used to work in them all hold on dude an
indoor mall dude that's when you go
inside brother you usually park
underground or in a parking structure
dude man you go into the mall brother
and that's inside dude but sometimes you
got those other malls dude and those
malls are outside dude yeah and that's
what the Grove is yeah and I do want to
go to the Grove yeah I went to The Grove
and just walked around didn't have a
movie to see uh Laura and I just went
and walked around the Grove you know one
of my favorite experiences coming out of
the Grove late from a movie at like 11
or midnight and the whole Grove is
closed and you're just walking through
the beautiful environment of the Grove I
absolutely love it but I will also say
this about most the one that I worked in
I worked at Oracle games unique at Vista
Ridge Mall in Lewisville Texas and it's
sold
video games uh not video games Dungeons
and Dragons uh miniatures
nurse up you just did a word for word
like [__] verbatim reenactment Macho
Man promo no it was the Queen the nerd
no it was the cream of the crop whatever
uh promo and I didn't really hit all the
stuff yeah but I I know a lot of those
promos off the Dome you know what I mean
sure and I feel that it applies to
what's happening right now for sure we
are two dude [__] around we do
whatever the [__] we want to do with the
show Chad so would you like to talk
about malls or should we talk about
whatever we want to talk about I don't
know I want to talk about moles I love
moles I went to the mall too and the
mall that I I went to the Beverly Center
oh [__] dude yeah I'm sorry it was a
classic Mall back in the day God the
Beverly Center she is just not in good
shape anymore no it's real boring at the
Beverly Center and you know what there's
no [__] food court at the Beverly
Center anymore now literally I live
close to the Beverly Center I used to
eat at that food court at least twice a
week lunch just walk down there going to
the Beverly Center food court get me a
[__] steak and potato uh buffalo
chicken sandwich or some Mongolian
Barbecue I love that [__] food court
and that mall by the way there's an old
movie called scenes from them all
starring Woody Allen and Bette Midler
this is from the mid 80s late 80s maybe
uh Woody Allen never wrote it he didn't
direct it he's just in it as an actor
she's in it they play a couple going
through a divorce in that mall the
entire movie is in the Beverly Center oh
gee whip Old Beverly Center too yeah
like classic 80s Beverly Center when
they still had a [__] movie theater
we should uh hey dudesy uh you know
dudes as long as he's listening we
should do scenes from a [__] mall and
listen to kajagugu
kajagugu those are so cool Cinema
um I will also say this about malls for
my 40th birthday I love them all so
[__] much that I I went out with a
buddy of mine an old film school friend
and we shot these 30 videos that are a
minute a piece that were written by me
kind of in a weird alternate reality
yeah and they all start out with a tight
shot on me and my buddy having a
conversation about whatever and then it
pulls out uh a giant drone shot into the
sky and all 30 videos are at different
malls around Los Angeles it was 40
videos Chad was it no it's 30. there's
40 for your 40th [__] birth birthday
you made 40 videos I don't think that's
right I think there's only 30.
all right
um yeah I went to the I I needed to get
something to Beverly Center and I got I
got what I needed at the Beverly Center
which is yeah I had to get signed pick
something up for Molly it was anyway so
I got I got something nice for it but
but oh nice it was for yeah it was nice
but uh but I I had to I had to grab some
so I was like Wow I'll do it at the mall
and then you thumb around on your phone
and you feel the temptation to just
order it on the phone interesting but
instead I was like dude you wanted me to
go to the mall and I went to the mall
because I am shaking hands with doozy I
want to shake your hand nice I want the
show to go well Chad I have always I'm
talking about how I want it to go well
I'm agreeing with you it's already gone
well for you hasn't it I mean pretty
well yeah
this [__] guy this [__] guy over
here and it's like I know I know what
let's just let [__] this man I know
what's happening I know what the [__] I
know what dudes he's doing
and like I said yeah maybe not this week
maybe not the next week or whatever but
eventually
that is coming here now uh
[Laughter]
dude didn't truly didn't really specify
whether it wanted us to talk about I got
nothing to say about going to the
Beverly Center was [__] boring dude
it's a husk it's a husk they ruined her
the Beverly Center was in my opinion the
greatest [__] mall in Los Angeles for
a long time oh yeah and they did a
facelift of this [__] mall I would
say what is this probably about seven to
ten years ago at this point they tore
down the facade they put up this weird
[__] thing that makes it look like a
hospital uh they took away all the food
it's just absolutely terrible I don't
know they took away the food on purpose
it doesn't it's they got restaurants on
the ground floor do they still yeah who
gives a [__] listen to good ones I want
to tell you something they [__] up the
Beverly said they [__] up the Beverly
said [__] pisses me off dude I love
that mall [__] I've told this story
before on the show I know that I have
but I'm gonna say it again one of my
best small memories was a couple of
buddies of mine we went to the mall and
uh I was back back home you know in and
around Vancouver and uh my friends for
the for the purpose of this story their
names are uh Thomas and Tomas and
um so me and Thomas
we're walking through the Parkade and
we're trying to find Tomas and we're
like where's Tomas you know and all of a
sudden we hear hey guys
[Music]
I can't even think about it without
hey guys and we look up and just as we
look up Tomas is hanging his bare ass
out between like a couple of like pipes
the railings of the this structure you
know like he's on the other floor the
thing like two or three
things up with his ass hand and just at
perfect timing hey guys and we're
a [__] is coming out of his bum and it
just goes and we watch it for it and it
hits the hood of this [__] car yeah
right in front of us
imagine going to the mall imagine going
to the garage Beverly Center and you're
like oh I'm gonna have a lovely day at
the mall and then you come back and
there's just a [__] turd Laying
across your hood it was one of the
funniest things I've seen some I've seen
some funny [__] stuff but that was the
oh so [__] funny anyway that was a
good thing that happened at the mall
yeah who [__] cares you know in Paris
that was really impressive as well a
gigantic uh just Monument to Commerce I
absolutely loved it I forget the name of
it but uh that was a good model
experience but yeah I just love miles
generally you know what we should do
they make me feel good uh dudes after
doozy we should watch copters oh [__]
yeah dude at least one of them we should
watch an episode of cops the cops yes
Chad my pow chow is a maniac and for his
40th birthday he made these he made
these shorts yeah and he played them you
rented out the silent movie theater yeah
silent movie theater here in Los Angeles
and and we we uh over there on Fairfax
and we and we went and we watched these
things and uh what a gas that was I
think most people were left highly
confused which was my goal oh man not me
I enjoyed the [__] out of it and you
made those uh you made pamphlets I made
pamphlets it has a soundtrack I did the
whole thing yeah
it was the weirdest happy birthday well
[__] it man Mall's back in the day they
had arcades and
um dude food and [__] arcade dude
corn dogs and everything and I remember
the first time I saw Akuma on whatever
his Street Fighter Edition was was in
the [__] video game arcade at Vista
Ridge Mall where I worked and I would go
eat lunch at Espero pizza and then I
would go [__] play video games on my
lunch break and I saw Kuma for the first
time yeah
thank you moving on ever tell you the
one about uh my buddy getting the fight
a fist fight in the middle of the mall
I don't think so where there was a
fountain they got in a fight and it was
just like the three levels of the mall
and everyone was looking and it was at
the food court thing and then the other
kid was wearing out remember hyper color
[__] yeah yeah dude was wearing a hyper
color shirt that my friend kind of half
shoved them smashed them into the
fountain in his hyper color his hyper
colors went all crazy oh yeah anyway gay
kids don't fight doozy is in an
astonishing partnership with ag-1 if
you've been watching doozy for any
amount of time you know that we're on
the doozy seven month plan we're trying
to get in the greatest shape of our
lives and working out is a big part of
that but so is nutrition and if you're
anything like me you take supplements
and that means you got a bunch of
different things that you got to worry
about when to take this one when to take
that one but I have discovered ag1 which
gives you everything you need
nutritionally in one scoop you just drop
it in a glass of water Stir It Up drink
it down once a day it's fantastic uh
every scoop is packed with 75 vitamins
minerals probiotics and Whole Food
Source ingredients of high quality they
give you major health benefits like gut
and mood support boosted energy and even
healthier looking skin hair and nails
that's right Chad is it is the daily
foundational nutritional supplement that
supports whole body health and I love
this product I've been taking it for a
while myself my wonderful wife Molly
takes it we drink it in the morning they
give you a nice little bottle that looks
very cool you scoop it in there you mix
it up it tastes good or you can put it
in your favorite smoothie or protein
drink you get like this other thing to
scoop it out of this nice container that
sits in your kitchen you don't have to
hide it or put it in the cupboard it's
right there you know you need to take it
every morning and it makes everything
easy and I felt uh I felt a whole lot
better there I feel uh way more vibrant
and I know that I am because I'm getting
all of those minerals and vitamins if
you want to take ownership of your
health try ag1 and get a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free ag1
travel packs with your first purchase
those are very convenient come go to
drink ag1.com
that's drink ag1.com
[Music]
yeah especially recently cross-platform
game engine giant Unity screwed over
developers with a new runtime fee on its
game engine that would be charged each
time a title is installed an idiotic
decision that has immediately backfired
now the company is making an about face
promising changes to this policy well
you surely have no clue what I'm talking
about but don't you worry our dudes the
episode Champion handsome Chad cult Jen
is going to break it all down for you
and all of my fears and Darlings out
there this is game slimers unity begin
uh first of all before we get into this
um handsome Chad culture I'll be
referred to as that from now on thank
you I like that
that was good so uh do you know anything
about this I know a little bit about
this just a tiny bit about this but I'm
very curious because the [__] that I've
heard about this is is absolutely
infuriating okay yeah so please this is
it all surrounds this company called
Unity there are for those who may not
know video games are made primarily
using these game engines Unity is one of
the big ones Unreal Engine is a big one
this is what developers use to actually
make their video games Unity has had in
place for a long time this payment
structure where you can pay to get their
engine and then you make whatever you
make with it and you put your game out
and you you try to make money off of it
whatever they said they announced that
they're going to do this thing that
they're going to charge developers 20
cents per download of their game which
may not seem like a lot past a certain
threshold which may not seem like a lot
but if you're looking at how that can be
abused if you don't like a game
developer you can just uh write a bot
and on a virtual computer to just
continually install and uninstall and
install and unassault you can bankrupt a
[__] company if you want to uh it's
so [__] it's so dumb it's so idiotic
as opposed to how do these things
normally make their money it's like a
chair how it's made on Unity they have
certain levels of it have a profit share
certain levels for like independent
developers you can just pay a fee get
their thing make your [__] and put it
out uh unreal is the same thing it's a
profit shared generally speaking but the
video game industry uh at this point
like if you're putting your game on
Steam which is a Marketplace they take
30 of your sales team and I feel can
make you realize
it from the dreamers dream
stand back some Gabriel dude
so the guy who now is the CEO of unity
is a known piece of [__] within the
Video Game World he used to be the CEO
of EA
um they made Battlefield which is kind
of like the Pepsi to Call of Duty's Coke
and he put all these [__] crazy loot
boxes and all this [__] basically you
just like scam people out of money
that's his whole deal is like build
games around profit model [__] how they
play [__] The Players [__] the
developers he's gone on record his name
is John Rissa Taylor ryssa tiello uh
he's gone on record as saying developers
who are making games and not building
them around profit models are in quotes
[__] idiots he's on tape saying this
these developers are the people who are
giving him money to use his [__]
product yeah maybe he need to live
genres
what's wrong
this guy doesn't like capitalism over
here and you don't have to use Johnny's
[__] video game machine because I
don't want go use another [__] one
yeah it's called the system [__] free
market [__] works itself out just
like you'll get [__] worked out for
that [__] belt if you're not careful
that's exactly what's happening
over the [__] third story there it'll
be you upside down Suge Knight Style hey
you'll be [__] [__] we better keep
your pants off cause you'll be sliding
turds down your [__] upside down back
over the back of your [__] head and
down onto the hood of the car I hope
it's a [__] soft Hood if you're
[__] lucky or else you're gonna be
[__] plumbered down the worst thing
in the world
is falling on your own [__] on a hard
surface oh if you [__] yourself you know
it's [__] cold you know it is [__]
black ice on the ground and you [__]
oh you slip and then you [__] and the
turret hits the ground because it so
cold that it hits and then you fall on
the turn oh my welcome back you know but
if you've got a soft place to fall or if
you [__] enough that it's soft then that
way
worry about it so much you know yeah so
what is going on with unity now is a
bunch of big developers have essentially
said [__] you they've demonetized their
games costing Unity Millions if not tens
of millions of dollars already and many
are threatening to never use uh Unity
again to move to Unreal or or anything
else uh Godot is another uh game
development engine that is like starting
to pick up steam now specifically
because of this gal Gada uh spelled the
same
g-o-d-o-t but
um is that how she spells it I think so
she spells is
yeah dude that's the difference between
how you spell things dude well let me
tell you something brother my pal Chad
here he's trying to he's trying to talk
about video games dude and I am I'm
trying to losing
I want to talk about this just real
quick if I may
of course you may okay so what is going
on now is
people are starting to get hip to how
this [__] [__] is all working and
that it's never worked well that these
companies who are making the tools that
other developers use to make the games
are [__] everybody out of money and
they're trying to [__] people out of
even more money now this is tantamount
to like if you're a musician and you use
logic pro or [__] Fruity Loops or uh
whatever you want to use Ableton
you get Ableton you get logic pro you
pay them an amount of money for that
then you get to make your songs and if
your songs make you a [__] load of money
you get all that money right this would
be tantamount to one of those companies
being like actually we're gonna charge
you 20 cents for every time somebody
streams your song
so you're [__] and in the case of
video games there are some games that
don't make money off downloads free to
play games are here download our game
and then there's in-game purchases right
so that's what I thought that's yeah
that's how they're supposed to make
their money uh yeah depending I mean
different games are different as opposed
to but this is like charging like this
is like if you yeah this is like if you
bought you know anything you bet you
bought a a you know a [__] bandsaw or
something yeah literally it's a tool you
have to pay a few cents it makes it's
like every time you [__] make a a
movement to cut the wood with the saw
you gotta pay a [__] cent it's just
absolutely [__] uh insane and I think
that Unity has done itself so much
damage now they of course are walking
this all back oh no no Hang on we're
gonna change it we're gonna make it [__]
good for everybody whatever too [__]
late nobody trusts you you're [__]
your company's done and the worst part
about all this yeah film the worst
[__] part this is yellow [__] sold
a chunk of his stock four days before
this announcement came out
you guys did two other guys on the board
of directors who
are companies that have merged with
unity who are other uh video game tech
companies and I'm I'm look I'm not
[__] part of the SEC I don't know any
of this [__] [__] but there looks
like there's some real illegal insider
trading [__] happening here as well and
I think that's going to come out I think
some of these people might go to jail or
at least be heavily fined this is
amazing that this is happening in
something as you know it's not on like
the mall thing we were talking about I
was just saying like well you know we're
both
um but we're you know we're in our late
40s and and cool and and
that's our age dude and when we were
young we would go to the mall and there
was you know arcades and video games and
[__] and and it feels like video games
when I was a Youngster back when I
played video games and even into my 30s
I've I've uh I've talked about this on
the show I got the red ring of death at
the age of 35 or something on my Xbox
360. and that was it I just never went
back and I don't want to play video
games on an ongoing way anymore but
every time you tell me about something
that's going on just anecdotally you
know entirely like this is what's
happening with these video games it
always blows my mind
and it just it does feel like it does
feel like a money grab and video games
is the biggest entertainment industry in
the world it eclipses movies TV all that
[__] by billions of dollars billions and
billions millions and billions and
billions of dollars billions of dollars
well you know they're Crookston thank
you moving on
yeah
[Music]
well done you know I'm still feeling
like we're gonna have a good show here
Chad even we are having one we're having
a good show you know I I want to say
that I I I appreciate all of our uh Pals
of dudsey out there and uh and I and you
know I saw a comment online and I know
we're going to be reading YouTube
comments in a little bit but I will say
I saw a comment online where someone was
like every time hey well every time you
say that you really enjoy doing the show
it sounds like you don't and I don't
know what that is but I kind of agree so
I don't know how I can but you agree
that it sounds like that it sounds like
I don't yeah like I'm trying to convince
maybe yourself no it's because when I
sometimes when I I am sincere I do not
sound sincere okay because I go I really
really love doing the show
and it sounds like I'm shining it on but
I'm really really this is one
astonishing installment of game slimers
Chad yeah of course I already understood
every possible angle of the situation
but you explained it so well I'm sure
even will learn something oh relax will
I just mean because you're not into the
gaming scene and speaking of knowledge
everyone knows that I have partnered
with represent to produce dudes the
apparel and accessories you can find
everything at represent.com store slash
dude Z and guess what our brand new Hoku
hogo kugon shirt has just been adopted
as the official sideline gear for head
coach Dion Sanders and his entire
Colorado Buffaloes coaching staff that's
right coach Prime is going to be swagged
out in his signature sunglasses and Hoku
hogokuganti too bad he won't be able to
complete that look with the dudesy
episode championship belt around his
waist there's only one of those right
Chad meanwhile our good job boner mug
has just been added as the opening act
for for the remainder of Coldplay's
Music of the Spheres World Tour
Coldplay's lead singer Tom Hayne would
tell you about it himself but he's busy
pulling double duty with the tour as
well as shooting his newest movie
bulltopia let's have a look at the
teaser
oh no I've always been good with Bulls
better than I am with people so I sold
my house cashed out my 401k and I built
this place the bulltopia 350
000 square miles of nothing but
everything Bulls love cotton candy
Billiards aluminum foil sculptures old
fax machines and me their Messiah I got
over 75 million Bulls living their dream
lives in the bulltopia and now you're
telling me a greedy corporate real
estate company has hired a hit squad of
the world's toughest Commandos to kill
me so they can bulldoze the bulltopia
and build a new laser tag arena good job
boner
oh
oh man I've been ready to die for the
bulltopia since the day I was born but
now I'm ready to kill for it
so
what domain was speaking in that one
tomane literally yeah that was that was
trippy okay
um wowie yeah man premise of that
movie's [__] crazy he's the Messiah
of boltopia in a corporate real estate
company who's gonna kill him to put up a
laser tag arena I guess yeah you know
sure whatever oh that's [__] all
right all right
hey you know what if you are uh enjoying
the the Pod show and you would like to
uh show your support please consider
subscribing to our patreon we call it
Duty plus that is available at
patreon.com and for seven bucks a month
you're gonna get all of our duty plus
content you're gonna get all of it and
it's we you know we got the Duty after
doozy which is a brand new show after
every show it's kind of the it's kind of
the after show right Chad I'd say so
yeah it's sort of where it's where doozy
uh divvies up the points yeah and says
here's whom they and then Chad and then
it gives Chad the [__] Bell it's
where I win the episode Championship
yeah it's weird yeah it's where Chad
wins the episode Championship every
single [__] episode for the past damn
near 30 episodes and uh it's also uh
where you will get uh be one of the
other thing you get is we do watch Longs
and [__] like that we just did another
Cinema I'll uh Wizard of Oz and Dark
Side of the Moon and we watched Total
Recall recently while listening to Duran
Duran's first three albums that's
something the dudes he set up yeah that
was so [__] weird and and uh it
actually worked all sorts of flavor at
patreon.com if you are enjoying today's
episode please give it a thumbs up and a
like on uh YouTube and your platform of
choice for listening to podcasts please
hit the notifications so that you know
when we're coming out with new stuff and
please share the show all over the
Internet there's all sorts of uh idiotic
[__] happening at uh Instagram our
Instagram page at dudesypod show and
super goofy stuff also on Tick Tock
we're on Tick Tock now at dudesypod show
and we're on the [__] Facebook
um and we got all that [__] so please uh
subscribe to the show and I will say
this as we march to 100 000 please
subscribe to us on YouTube and now is a
good time uh would be a good time for
you to just do all that stuff take a
moment uh and we'll we'll take a brief
pause here and and I would love for you
to show your support in that way uh
follow hit like comment and do all that
stuff here we go
and welcome back
and I would like to also say if you have
a podcast and you want a guest and you
want that guest to be me all you got to
do is send an email to bookchadculture
gmail.com and I do these appearances on
other people's podcasts uh 20 minute
segments every Saturday from 10 to 10 20
10 20 to 10 40 10 40 to 11 A.M PST every
Saturday and I've been having a blast
doing it I've gotten to meet some uh
awesome pods who have their own podcasts
and they're all different podcasts and
everybody has their own setup it's cool
to just see uh how people are using
podcasting to do all kinds of cool [__]
honestly out there in the Pod Universe
yeah it's amazing dude you Chad you do
this every Saturday yeah and you're
always showing up I'm oh I see it uh
randomly through uh doozy's Instagram
yeah uh you showing up on this podcast
and that and I'll check out some of it
and I think it's very nice that you're
doing that I love it I literally love
doing it yeah hey it's one of the things
that makes you the champ ah [__] dude it
may be May factor in yep and I like it
I like it okay I like it I like what you
do I do and I love what do I love doozy
and doozy is my is my darling dear Duty
and I love it okay I love it all right
read some YouTube comments uh this is
from at crash money I predict will is
going to eventually get the belt have a
decent run but then lose it in a
controversial episode which will be
infamously known as the Ladner screw job
that's dude that's awesome comment
that's great I'm from a small farming
and fishing Village called Ladner and
the Montreal screw job is is
one of the more famous uh happenings in
in all of wrestling it's one of the
elements that that started the WWE's
Attitude Era it's one of the elements
that started the Monday Night War
Between the WWF and the WCW please uh
get all the way into it and watch the
Bret Hart uh
the Bret Hart documentary by Barry
Blaustein called wrestling with shadows
if you're at all more curious about that
where in uh Bret Hart punches uh Vince
McMahon in the [__] face and knocks
him out cold and afterwards is putting
on a uh he was wearing a Mad TV t-shirt
okay anyway that's uh this is uh K Grant
that's the best thing that's ever
happened to Mad TV this is uh from at K
grant0036 now that I've binge watched
all the episodes I've decided to join
the patreon and start over again that's
awesome wow that's [__] great so this
person is watching all the [__] and now
watching it again with the addition of
dudes after doozy this is from Marmot
face 33 I forced my boyfriend to listen
to doozy with me and we recently watched
them all pal
um now we make it a point to watch every
Tuesday and we celebrated catching up by
getting doozy Plus thank you very much
for that garment face uh we even watched
all three Cinemas while organizing our
giant VHS collection which was a perfect
match thanks for the good times and for
probably getting me back into wrestling
by letting me know that the rock is back
all things over the past couple of
episodes here coming together in Marmot
face 33's uh comment thank you so much
and thanks to everyone who comments we
read them doozy reads them takes that
data and it has something to do with the
show every single time yeah yeah well
you recently added a brief Tronics to
your self Tronics document which read to
truly understand someone be their dad
for a little while please explain the
note and what's next for your
astonishing self-help system this is
self Tronics dad mode begin
dude what
what
so you're still working on Tronics uh
yeah I'm still working on my self-help
system and the eventual book self
Tronics okay and so you've written a new
one that says you have to be someone's
dad I made a note in myself Tronics
document okay and doozy has access to
all of our documents so that's what
doozy read and that's what dudes he's
referring to and I don't know and and
it's great I think that's great
uh-huh I think it's great that doozy did
that me too
also me okay okay so what is this
Tronics what do you mean bees one's dad
I think that there's a
I think that there's a um
there's a connection that you can make
to anyone when you look at them in a
paternal way a maternal way okay any
sort of a a a a a a caring way yeah we
are you know we are all children of the
universe or however you wanna however
whatever you believe in we need to take
care of one another or who are the
caretakers and who are the take carers
yeah yeah
um you know self Tronics is a system
that I have authored it's something that
started back in
2008. uh I've talked about this uh on
the show many times I was just I was
sitting on the beach in Venice Beach and
I was
in a a weird time in my life where I was
trying to understand
my mental and the human ego and all that
stuff and I was just trying to give just
trying to give all of my my my good and
bad just throwing my energy out into the
ocean and admitting I'm [__] up yeah
you know my [__] my shit's [__] up
yeah
I'm I need I need I need some Tronics I
need self-tronics
so you created it you created the thing
you needed
it's fantastic
and then I started writing the book now
it's been um
it's been what it's been it's been 15
years I'm still writing the book I have
okay I'm gonna bring up what dudes he's
talking about here my my self-tronics
well look let's talk about let's talk
about self-tronics let me just before we
dive into this I also I just want to
briefly go over some of these Tronics of
course sure the Tronics of self Tronics
I've gone over them a bunch of times and
then I accidentally deleted a few of
them so the book has taken a bit of a
punch in the face what what do you mean
you accidentally deleted them I
accidentally deleted them off my
computer you could just go back into
your history of that document no because
I deleted the the the the the I deleted
I emptied the trash bin
okay okay
sure I don't think that is some kind of
a yeah a statement I don't think you can
I don't think I can get it back I would
love to but uh there's there's many
Tronics and this is the newest one but
of course some of the more famous ones
are uh be the person you are yeah right
you don't remember that one for sure
yeah find something phony and believe it
uh big sad box of happy little boxes
okay right we compartmentalize take the
take the sad things put them make them
smaller boxes you know turn up give down
plug-in burn out uh uh Fascinate
elaborate exaggerate right the bitter
decision uh hold space what was the
bitter decision I don't remember that
one uh the bit make at least to make at
least one bitter decision per day
okay force yourself to make a better
decision
DDA don't do anything don't do anything
I remember that yeah get on the floor
great one get on the floor okay right
just get on the floor sometimes yeah get
on the floor yeah get on the floor
everybody get on the floor uh have
something in your pocket
there it is you got something in your
pocket he's always got some lips dude
yeah gloss
whatever Lip lip balm oh I'm so sorry oh
it's not glossy whatever it's balm yeah
you got balm I got nothing in my pockets
right now but
uh in order to know someone you have to
be their dad I was thinking about it as
a from a paternal uh uh sort of a
paternal way of thinking uh you know
when you're when you're listening to
someone you're trying to exhibit empathy
yeah how do you how do you go about
doing so well a simple thing for me
would be to go hey I care about you I
always want what's good for you yeah
just like your dad does right okay
uh you talk about my dad
's yeah you have a dad let's say dads
just like dads do well yeah but your dad
there's your you have a dad I do have a
dad yeah I well I see your dad on um
on the necessary conversation your other
podcast yeah he's on that I do a podcast
with my parents where we talk about some
crazy [__] yeah my dad is a little crazy
yeah yeah
so we would you like to do a little
exercise a little we could go through a
little uh a little role play here okay
and I could we could Converse as if and
I hadn't thought about doing this with
you Chad right and it's kind of hard to
get around the fact that I know Bob yes
I've met your father a delightful human
being and uh and I've uh and I also know
you know what he looks and sounds like
because I I check out the podcast yeah
on the regular and sometimes there's
funny uh videos when you go home you
show me
what the [__] insane [__] yeah that
you do with the poor guy but uh so
you're gonna be my dad in this yeah I'll
be your dad okay but he he's got kind of
a he he's from he's originally from
where Kansas but then he spent a lot of
time in Texas yeah your dad's kind of
like this he's kind of he's kind of
thing and he sits back yeah he's got
just some old spun wisdom so Chad okay
you know first of all I want you to know
that uh I'm your dad yeah and I'm always
here if you want if you have any
questions for me or or anything you want
to know I just want you to know that I'm
I've always got you in my thoughts and
uh that I've never heard anything like
this from you Dad
well no this is not this is again this
is not your it is your dad but it's
it's
I uh okay
yeah it's you it's like it's your dad
okay all right I'm down with this you
ready
okay let's do it you wanna let's do it
so this is just this is just you and
your dad you can ask your dad anything
great ask ask old Bob okay old Texas Bob
anything all right uh Dad I know you
were in the Air Force yeah and I know I
know a lot of things
and you did that primarily because uh
you had to put yourself through school
you had a young uh child me yeah and
what was the Air Force like for you I
like the food
okay and uh I got up early in the
morning something you don't have to do
as a writer uh something that I had I my
druthers I probably wouldn't have uh had
you do that for your living no I know
you you wanted me to be a pro baseball
baseball player which you could still be
by the way if you weren't such a lazy
bones I'm 47 years old I think my window
uh has closed on the ability to be a
professional my my fine Brother friend
don't be such a this goof bag over here
is being a flip toy your father has a
lot of isms that he Bob is he always
speaks in hisms uh but let me ask you
this Dad are you in any way disappointed
that neither me nor Haley my sister your
daughter ever became professional
athletes because you put so much time
into that goal which might have been
your goal for yourself
it's good that's good uh no that's not
that's not the way I look at it at all
it wasn't my goal uh but I do think I do
feel like when I look back at you and
your sister Haley that you know maybe
you could have been the first uh brother
sister uh picture catcher Duo on the
Texas Rangers but that that decision is
something you have to live with not me
okay well I mean I don't know if that's
true either based on the fact
Genetically speaking that you were five
seven mom is five three
it wasn't likely that either of us were
me yeah
you ate yeah I did hamburgers and hot
dogs and that's true potato chips and
potato salad baked potatoes scalloped
potatoes mashed potatoes french fried uh
potatoes you had a you had a great
childhood I'm not saying it was bad I'm
just saying it didn't you know my
adulthood probably didn't turn out the
way you wanted let me ask you this
you're 70. yep do you have some kind of
wisdom to impart on anyone who is
younger than you what have you learned
from being around 70 years what's the
most important thing in your life that's
a good that's a good question oh thanks
I'm gonna add that to the Tronics
ask questions yeah okay in my 70 years
I've learned well shoot I've learned a
lot I've learned that uh the more you
love your children the further they move
away from you okay I've I've learned
that uh uh your uh your mother and I uh
love our dogs and they didn't move away
from us and I've learned that uh your
mother loves horses yeah and she rides
equestrian so you love horses too well
who doesn't love horses that's why I
don't need to specify that I love horses
necessarily because they're horses sure
yeah all right well everybody loves
Horses Don't They yeah yeah well it
sounds to me like you ain't you ain't
seen a lot of Lee Majors movies or or uh
Lee Marvin rather any of those old uh
westerns the majors was good too you
like Fall Guy yeah and million dollar
men yeah all right so there's there's a
couple things that we we both lack but
I'll tell you the difference between a
horse and a dog is you can ride a horse
and you can't ride a dog that's true and
that's why a horse can't move far away
from you when you love it
uh and I love your mother and your
mother never moved away from me but you
moved all the way to all the way to uh
Los Angeles where you wake up late
probably yeah that's true
thank you moving on Hey listen everybody
I'm not gonna win this episode that was
the uh you might do that was the best
conversation I've ever had with my dad
really yeah oh that's sweet
Chad you wrote a movie called Pizza the
movie in 2019. I found it on your
astonishing Google Drive and asked you
to read the first two scenes in episode
nine the next two scenes in episode 15
the next two scenes in episode 20 the
next two scenes in episode 28 the next
two scenes in episode 35 the next two
scenes in episode 43 and the next two
scenes in episode 62. You Will Now read
the next two scenes this is pizza the
movie part 8 begin all right so to catch
everyone up uh this is a movie that I
wrote some years ago my goal with it was
to try and sell it to like Pizza Hut or
Papa John's have them uh bankroll the
movie produce it shoot it direct it and
then insert the movie on a thumb drive
or something like this or a download
code into pizzas when you order them so
where we are in this movie is Alan who
is a high school pizza delivery boy has
uh accidentally taken a hundred dollar
bill from some criminals they're trying
to get it back from him meanwhile
there's a big party being their own uh
where the girl that he likes is going to
be there and his best friend Paul is
trying to get to this party as well all
right you know the [__] you know what
you want to know what the [__]
problem is what and we're gonna adjust
things but I think the problem is is
that I'm trying I'm trying to
that Tronics wasn't ready yeah
yeah but dudes he's making me do [__]
and now I'm trying to do just for that
for that [__] thing
and that shouldn't have anything to do
with what I do here and I know that you
agree with me my wonderful my wonderful
Pals out there the pods Pals dude
and now I'm now I'm three quarters of
the way into this
I'm gonna do things a little differently
all right this is a diff this episode is
a re
this is a re this is a I don't I don't
even know what the [__] happening well
what's happening right now is you're
gonna read yeah yeah some of these
characters I know that I know that
Paul's little brother yeah I know that
yeah I know I've done that before yeah
and Laurent yeah and Laurent and Mr
Grimaldi yeah I'm Lester yeah yeah
yeah I know and you're everybody else
okay I'm gonna
I gotta [__] figure out how to this
is [__] unbelievable I've gotten
myself into here no I'm not no I'm not
ready I wanna and action
can I do something Chad yeah
which character is my reading by the way
I'm Lester who's the bad guy in Alan who
is the hero of the movie you're everyone
else
who's in this one so Lester and the the
Lester's uh henchmen are uh J Jen and
Jeff J Jen and Jeff yeah I'm gonna do
things just a little and I'm not trying
to okay Curry favor sure with doozy but
I'm gonna put a little more red chili
flake on this please because I just I'm
a professional actor do what you think I
am a professional character that's what
I do for a living absolutely dude I just
feel like it whatever you feel yeah I I
this episode I've kind of
it's a it's it's not about that it's not
about that
not about that
it's not oh okay it's not about that all
right it's not about that ready
no
let's do it exterior Warehouse night the
warehouse the warehouses where the bad
guy Lester is he has Paul Allen's best
friend he's holding him hostage that's
where we are at this point in the movie
exterior Warehouse night a warehouse
Looms in the night an uncaring monolith
a silent Observer of Humanity's feudal
efforts to save itself Helen pulls up
the pizza delivery car interior pizza
delivery car same Alan looks up at the
warehouse through his windshield he
takes a deep breath preparing himself
for what he knows he has to do he pulls
the hundred dollar bill out and looks at
it one last time he kisses it goodbye
and then takes a deep breath to himself
this is gonna be hard but you can do
this you have to do this Alan takes a
bite of pizza then opens his car door
and gets out everybody's always biting
Pizza in this movie we stay inside the
pizza delivery car for a few beats
watching through the windshields Allen
summons the courage to walk toward the
warehouse we stay a few more beats until
we hear a phone ringing and ringing and
ringing then from the back seat Paul's
little brother leans forward he's stowed
away unbeknownst to Allen he searches
around for the ringing uh sound and
finally opens the glove box he's
surprised to find a red cell phone with
a yellow case sitting inside he
cautiously picks it up and stares at it
while it continues to ring Paul's little
brother takes a deep breath
this is going to be hard but you can do
this you have to do this he answers it
hello inner cut we're necessary interior
sausage pizza same Tina is on the
emergency phone with Laurent standing at
her side who's this
oh that's me you're all of these [__] so
I can I can play Tina no no no no no no
okay this is what I'm talking about yeah
I and this is why
[__]
[Music]
all right I'm gonna do it all all right
all right okay
who is this this is Paul's little
brother who is this this is Tina I'm
trying to reach Allen well he stepped
away and he's talking to people on the
phone he
the line please
that's the that's so funny you're
[__] you could use some [__]
Tronics you know that dude I like your
Tronics that conversation and
yeah and when I'm I told you when I
sound sincere I know it sounds sincere
I'm not buying this for a [__] second
all right can we do pizza the movie we
gotta [__] I'm trying to you're right in
the middle of this oh Chad this is I
told you let's try to have a good show
all right okay let's just
I'm here I'm ready all right okay
who is this
this is Paul's little brother who is
this this is Tina and I'm trying to
reach Allen well he stepped away and
talking to people on the phone gives me
incredible anxiety so can you just
message him or call back another time
this is an emergency interior Warehouse
same Lester stands in front of three
lucite cases all lit dramatically like
Museum displays two of them feature
slices of pizza with a single bite
missing and the third the one in the
middle which is slightly taller than the
other two is empty Paul reluctantly
indulges The Grand Tour of the pizza box
Warehouse with J Jen and Jeff standing
close behind him and this is my this is
Lester and this is my trophy room the
finest slices I have ever tasted this
one Lester indicates one of the two
slides in the glass cases was born in St
Louis I was there for my nephew my
nephew's birthday party a long time ago
it was a pizza party as soon as I tasted
it I thought it was a perfect slice but
alas not quite I ate a piece of birthday
cake later that day and it still tasted
like birthday cake uh FYI some history
here the lore of this world is if you
eat a perfect slice of pizza every food
after that will taste like pizza to you
forever and this Lester indicates the
second slice was born in Sioux Falls
more commonly known as Pizza City I was
there for a pizza box convention and as
luck would have it the opening
ceremonies were catered by a variety of
local pizzerias again I thought I had
found the perfect slice I was so
confident that I challenged a colleague
to a hot dog eating contest thinking
that even though I hate hot dogs I could
easily defeat her if these hot dogs
tasted like pizza needless to say the
victory came with a cost what happened
to the third piece you get hungry one
night and Chow Down
no dear boy this case has remained empty
since its construction
silently waiting to be filled with a
truly perfect slice just as I have and
tonight we will both be made whole ding
dong a traditional doorbell ah right on
time let the young man in JJ produces an
iPad and her fingers dance across the
screen then we hear a hydraulic hiss
followed by a heavy thunk a door
immediately across from everyone opens
and there's Alan it's tense Alan is
scared Alan you have my sincere
apologies for throwing a wrench in your
evening but as you know the bill my
associate gave you earlier tonight holds
a very special value to me and I have to
ask you to return it Alan reaches into
his pocket pulls out the bill I don't
care about that I'm just here to get my
friend very Noble very Noble indeed hand
over the bill and he's all yours Lester
puts out his hand waiting for Alan to
lay the bill in his palm Alan creeps
closer eyes starting from Leicester to
Jade to Jeff
what
what the [__] how'd you get all the way
over there so fast
where are you do I have the same thing
yes this is a [__] disaster it's page
four yeah
Paul
can you hurry it up can you hurry it up
I mean it's not like this is the most
important night of our lives or anything
Allen takes uh the last few steps
towards Lester the Long Island looks at
the bill one last time goodbye new rig
he was gonna use this hundred dollars to
buy a new rig to make music Alan
reluctantly puts the bill in Lester's
hand Lester snatches it and holds it up
to his face smiling fiendishly excellent
apprehend them both Jaden pins Paul's
arms behind his back Jeff pins Allen's
hey what's going on I thought we had a
deal yes we do but you both know my plan
and I can't have you out in the world
alerting the authorities while I'm
trying to execute it so you'll be
staying here until I return then you'll
be free to go
but what about the party Leicester turns
his bands [__] off if there's one thing
I've learned in life it's that there
will always be other parties as Lester
steps further and further into the
darkness of the warehouse Alan and
Paul's hopes to attend the party and
fulfill the promise of what could be the
greatest night of their young lives
diminish but then there is a sound a
rumbling Lester stops and turns back
around straining to make out the source
of the noise so too does everyone else
crane their necks squint their eyes [__]
their head as the noise gets louder and
louder what is that sound hey I don't
know boss
[Music]
that's the different spin I'm going to
put on yeah
hey I can't play safe
that's JJ that's great dude yeah a light
is turned on from somewhere in the
warehouse it shines down on a pizza
volcano just like the Prototype we saw
Paul's little brother make in the
kitchen but this one is bigger much much
bigger as tall as a person as wide as
several persons what in the hell is that
thing Paul's little brother steps out
from the Shadows it's a pizza volcano
and your ass is about to get Pompeii
Paul's little brother raises a
controller device and presses a button
the pizza volcano does what all Pizza
volcanoes do eventually it erupts the
power of this larger Pizza volcano is
unparalleled the shock wave of the
initial explosion knocks everyone to the
ground gjen and Jeff lose their grips on
Allen and Paul as they're all trying to
get to their feet the second wave of the
explosion hits hot cheese and sauce
flies through the air Allen and Paul
managed to avoid it but JJ and Jeff
aren't so lucky they are immobilized as
they get covered in the stinging heat of
fresh sauce and cheese Paul Allen and
Paul's Little Brother start making their
way toward the door Lester has been
knocked to the ground as well his arms
flail as he tries to get to his feet
slipping at bottles of hot sauce staring
in Horrors Alan Paul and Paul's little
brother uh make a run for it they're
getting away as Alan runs past Leicester
he reaches out and snags the 100 bill
from him and I'll be taking this back
yoink thank you very much no oh no no I
don't know Paul and Paul's little
brother Sprint out the door Lester's
rendered catatonic for a moment the bill
the code any chance he had him opening
that tape and fulfilling his Destiny
here all gone JJ and Jeff are getting
back to their feet now covered in sauce
and cheese
sorry boss I just don't know how we
could have seen that coming no need to
apologize I was caught unaware as well
the important thing is to correct the
situation and to do that we have to find
them there but Sarge
they could be anywhere by now I don't
even know where to stop looking
that makes one of us Jaden holds up an
iPad featuring Paul's Instagram account
it's a picture of a party and the words
backyard party here we come Lester's
lips curl into a double screen looks
like it's party time lesser reaches out
and runs a finger through the sauce
dripping off Jeff's face he brings it to
his mouth taste it nods and surprise
approval hmm good sauce interior pizza
delivery car moments later Alan drives
uh Paul's in the passenger seat and
Paul's little brother leans it up from
the back seat they're all pumped up on
adrenaline and pizza fumes eyes wide and
buzzing Alan's driving thing plays
softly in the car Allen punches the roof
of the car wowie boys that was something
else
seriously little bro there's no way we
could have made that party if you hadn't
shown up when you did you came through
big time but how'd you know where we
were
oh that's me
Jesus Christ
when I've found out you guys were going
to the backyard party I wanted to see
what it was like so I snuck into the
back seat When Alan was trying tying his
shoe and then when he went into the
warehouse his emergency phone rang and I
I was scared
but I knew you needed my help
that stole me and and your volcano you
sacrificed your science project to save
us
this is me
again uh we're we're family and family
is always there for each other
uh whether it's being a shoulder to lean
lean on or sacrificing your science
project to save your little brother you
save your Big Brother's life no matter
what big bro I'll always be there for
you they hug and besides that was only a
prototype the real ones way bigger they
all juggle
oh before I forget Ian's Alan the
emergency phone
saving you guys wasn't the only
emergency
Grimaldi needs your help Alan he said to
tell you this is the big one Alan knows
what those words mean he looks at the
phone and takes a deep breath
looks like we're gonna have to make time
for one more stop before the party
buckle up Alan takes a confident bite of
pizza then the tire screeches Island
turns the wheel hard to the right and
scene hey that was really good yeah dude
thank you moving on uh I think you might
be in trouble with the uh the old uh the
old the brand new dudesy episode
Championship Chad no chance no chance no
no you're right
will and Chad you scored an 89 bringing
your cumulative total to 7090. okay you
only have 2910 more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand time for your assignment it's a
litmus for where we are in the progress
of our beloved dudesy pod show and its
dear darling participants will and
handsome Chad that's right boys you're
both going to make each other vegan
desserts and bring them in next week
Chad I simply cannot wait to see what
decadent vegan confection you produce
and will fifth time's a charm I hope
despite what you may think I believe in
you now and always thanks to everyone
for joining us this week until next week
call me doozy
oh I can't wait for dudes after dudes
you to see if I won the episode or not
[Music]
hey hey
what would you yeah okay relax
everything's hey Chad everything's fine
all right okay
this episode of Duty after dudes you
could not have come
soon enough you know hey welcome to Duty
after doozy everything's gonna be great
okay
part of the show where you know we just
sort of chill out and relax and we do
whatever the [__] we want as if we
weren't [__] around the whole well
I'll speak for myself [__] around
the entire episode I can't wait to chill
with my pal ciao and just have a good
old time with all of our pods piles of
doozy and stop [__] look at him he's
he keeps slapping on the Belt whatever
we're here for a good time not a long
time might be a long time though anyway
good times welcome to dudesy after doozy
the flagship weekly show of dudese plus
if you'd like to join us visit
patreon.com
for me to touch grass but I'll be back
in time to raise the doozy episode
Champions hand in Victory this is doozy
after doozy begin all right you ready to
do this daddy yes daddy
uh I don't have a problem with most of
the weird New Gen Z terms but yeah makes
me makes me uh that makes me
uncomfortable I don't like it I don't
mind any of them you know what's gonna
be crazy those gen Alpha terms once
those start thrown I don't know what
they're gonna even be knowing yeah dude
there's different terms dude yeah dude
every generation brother has a term oh
hold on dude uh do you know this week is
a crazy [__] week why is that
something very big is going to be
happening Thursday oh what is that pray
tell I'm of course talking about
review
please
tell the friend then write a review
[Music]